[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
the contentious case of kyle rainhouse
we enter day two of verdict watch as a
jury deliberates in wisconsin and i
think these people are as competent as
the educated people and many of them are
educated
uh to make these decisions meanwhile
supporters and protesters take to
kenosha i was just so compelled to come
and show support for him we're going to
get a serious win here today we hear
from both sides plus defendant travis
mcmichael takes the stand in the death
of a mont arbory trial i want to
give my side of the story i want to
explain what happened and to uh
to be able to
say what happened from the way i see
and later the tiger king is back anybody
that's followed this knows that
joe's still in prison
and carol's still not in prison long
crime daily sits down with the attorney
for joe exotic who says his client
deserves a new trial law on crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome i went to law on crime daily i'm
brian buckmeyer along with terry austin
jurors asked to see videos of the night
kyle reinhaus shot three men killing two
of them as they deliberate our anjanet
levy joins us now live outside the
kenosha county courthouse with arguments
about the video and some comments from
judge shader about criticisms he and the
attorneys have received
well brian there were arguments about
how these jurors would get to watch
these videos and where and remember that
video it's drone video that we've seen
so many times that shows the shooting of
joseph rosenbaum by kyle rittenhouse the
defense actually has requested a
mistrial over that piece of video now
prosecutors the prosecution and defense
agreed that the current case law
requires jurors be brought into the
courtroom to watch videos prosecutors
said jurors should get to watch the
video as many times as they like but the
defense felt the jurors should be
limited in how many times they could
view the video
judge schroeder felt the jurors should
be allowed to watch the video as many
times as they feel they needed to and he
felt that restricting the jurors was
insulting to them
there was a time when the
people educated people in the town where
the
the physician and the lawyer and the
maybe the school teacher and the
preacher
um
and the rest of the people were farmers
so obviously they weren't as smart as
those educated people right
that's never been the belief of the
founders of our country it's never been
true
and i think these people are as
competent as the educated people and
many of them are educated
uh to make these decisions and that's
where the
founders of our country put the uh
the power not with us
so i think it's insulting to the jury to
tell them they have to have these
restrictions on their viewing
now as i mentioned the defense requested
a mistrial over that piece of drone
video that was shot by a citizen and was
shown to the jury now written house's
attorneys claim that they did not
receive a high-resolution copy of the
video only a low-quality version the
prosecution says the video shows
rittenhouse provoking the confrontation
with joseph rosenbaum by raising his gun
at him first prosecutors say they turned
over the video via email and it was
compressed in that process unbeknownst
to them
the judge cleared the courtroom so the
jurors could watch that video on a big
screen tv
the state objected to that mistrial
request and judge schroeder has not yet
ruled on it meanwhile during all of this
in the middle of these arguments judge
schroeder talked about some criticism
that he and the attorneys in the case
have received and he discussed that at
length
when i talked about
um
problems with the media when this trial
started
that's
we're there in part not not fully but in
part because of grossly irresponsible
handling of
what comes out of this trial i will tell
you this
uh i'm going to think long and hard
about uh live television but trial again
next time i don't know i i've always
been a firm believer in it because i
think the people should be able to see
what's going on but when i see
what's being done it's really quite
frightening frightening that's the right
word
and judge schroeder said he felt that
there was a lot of misinformation coming
out of the trial and being reported he
also said he was upset by the treatment
of the five lawyers in this case he said
that he's worked with all of them on
cases in the past he says that they are
all competent and he feels what's being
done to them some of the harassment is
shameful
brian
thanks ange joining us today is criminal
defense attorney julie reynoldman and
terry austin
judge trader has a tendency to digress
from the subject sometimes quoting
literature or even the bible how do you
think the jury is responding to these
digressions
well i guess it really depends on the
personality of each of the jurors now
keep in mind a lot of his
what some might describe as
transgressions and misbehavior and kind
of off topic happen when the jury's not
there and so the jury's not necessarily
the wiser to it
i i do always say that if a jury
respects the judge
a the case runs smoother and sometimes
if the judge has some inclination or
some bias towards one side or the other
then the jury may go along with what
they believe the judge's bias is um this
is a strange one the judge
you know is quite quirky he's gotten a
lot of things right i think he's gotten
a lot of things wrong but again each
juror has their own perception as to
what they think of what this judge
really is like makes sense terry there
was a discussion on wednesday about
whether the jury would view media inside
the courtroom what are the advantages of
having the media in the courtroom
well i think there are lots of
advantages brian having the media there
first of all the public gets an
opportunity to see what is going on this
is a high profile case and the public
wants to know what's happening and i
think if judge shader basically says
from now on he's no longer going to
allow the media just because he doesn't
like the criticisms and some of the
criticisms are well earned the fact that
he said you can't use the word victim
the fact that he's treated the
prosecution so poorly i think it would
be a shame if he actually ended up
closing his courtroom to the public and
the defendant has a right to have a
public trial in addition under the sixth
amendment yeah right on both accounts
for sure and judge trader discussed
other issues for which he felt he was
criticized right
yeah and one of those was something that
happened on the first day of jury
selection when the he allowed kyle
rittenhouse to reach into that tumbler
and pull the numbers out
to select the alternate jurors he said
that's something he started about 20
years ago after he had a case with a
black defendant in racine which is near
here and he said that the clerk picked
the alternates in that case and it
excluded the one black juror from the
panel so he said he started doing that
so that the defendant could reach in
there and there would be no question
about the fairness of that process yeah
it makes sense i can see where he's
getting at where i think the word was
best used was quirky the different
things that he does in the court
definitely different than i think what
we've seen in in brooklyn julie i know
you both practice in new york city and
so maybe that's where their criticisms
are coming from but i'm not sure if
closing off the court as terry said
would be the smartest response to this
of course uh justice is best seen in the
light not in the dark thank you everyone
for your input still ahead on law and
crime daily our cobra house coverage
continues from wisconsin angelina hears
from both supporters and protesters
outside the kenosha county courthouse
all that and more after the break
[Music]
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
the three men charge will now stand
trial for live galado gabo coverage of
the trial subscribe to law and crime on
youtube tv today
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily we
continue our coverage from wisconsin in
the trial of kyle rittenhouse let's
check back in with angenette levy
outside of the courthouse
brian supporters of kyle rittenhouse are
here outside the courthouse along with
people who want to see him convicted and
one of those is the uncle of jacob blake
he is the man whose shooting by kenosha
police sparked that unrest in august of
2020 where kyle rittenhouse ended up
shooting those three men
justin blake has been here at the
courthouse every day during trail
outside and i asked him about the jury's
request to see all of those videos
they're asking to see the videos my
sister if they focus on the videos we're
going to get a serious win here today
that means he's going to jail maybe not
on our cars but he's not going home
today they throw out all the uh
speaking and all the grandeur of the the
lawyers and the rhetoric and their focus
on those
videos which is to put proof in the
pudding
also here are those supporters of kyle
rittenhouse they feel he did nothing
wrong and was justified in shooting
those men
kyle rittenhouse is part of this
community
he was running he was walking around
with cleaning off
graffiti um helping people he helped the
guy with the shoulder
he was a young decent man and hearing
him in the courtroom i was just so
compelled to come and show support for
him because
i would be proud to have a child like
that
and one of the written house supporters
actually showed up on day two of
deliberations here at the courthouse
with a megaphone and some type of long
gun the deputies approached him and told
him he needed to keep that at least a
thousand feet away from the courthouse
brian
thanks angeannette now to news out of
california kobe bryant's widow is
ordered to turn over nearly five years
of therapy records amidst an ongoing
lawsuit she brought against los angeles
county early this week a judge ruled
vanessa bryant must turn over her mental
health records dating back to january
2017. all this comes months after a
lawsuit filed by bryant alleging she
suffers severe emotional distress and
mental anguish after county workers
leaked photos to the press of the
helicopter crash that killed her husband
and daughter kobe bryant and 13 year old
gianna were among the nine people who
died in the crash in january 2020. in a
recent deposition vanessa bryant
testified that she is traumatized from
the incident has trouble sleeping and is
depressed a judge ruled bryant has until
november 29th to produce the mental
health documents the trial is set to
begin on february 22nd 2022
switching coasts now to news out of
washington as a self-described q anon
shaman is sentenced to 41 months in
prison for his role in the january 6
insurrection at the u.s capitol this
marks the longest sentence handed down
for the offenders
thirty-three-year-old jacob chansley
pled guilty to one count of unlawfully
obstructing official proceedings in a
federal court on wednesday chansley
acted as a key figure during the attack
where he infamously marched through the
capitol wearing a horned helmet while
congress confirmed president joe biden's
presidential victory the defense argued
that jamsey suffers from significant
mental health issues and cannot be held
completely responsible for his actions
ahead of the sentencing chansey was held
in jail for 10 months
coming up on law and crime daily the
so-called tiger king says he deserves a
new trial after a murder for higher
conviction
plus the death of a mod arbory we take
you inside the courtroom where defense
attorney kevin goff makes his opening
statement and defendant travis mcmichael
takes a stand all that and more after
the break
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
defendant travis mcmichael who shot and
killed 25 year old ahmad aubrey takes a
stand in his own defense
mcmichael and his father gregory
mcmichael face several charges in the
death of ahmad arbury along with
neighbor william roddy bryant all three
defendants are charged with malice
murder felony murder and aggravated
assault in february of 2020 gregory and
travis mcmichael tailed aubry in their
pickup truck as he went for a jog travis
michael eventually shot aubry claiming
self-defense he says he believes aubrey
was breaking into homes in the
neighborhood brian followed along in his
own pickup truck and recorded the
incident on video on wednesday trousers
michael took the stand detailing past
break-ins in his family's neighborhood
when he says he feared for his safety
having that experience what i just said
that you know with him drawing they're
acting like he's throwing the weapon and
then running into the house and then
seeing the video that he's walking
walking around so nonchalant in that
that house kind of
it started me a little bit that
having that just happened just catching
him
creeping through that front yard and
obviously trying to
uh avoid detection and then doing what
he did there and then going into the
house and then walking around in there
like it's no big deal was
was alarming alarming why because
i wouldn't think anyone
acting normal would do that
and
somebody that's
that's willing to
act like they're
they have a gun or act like that they
will harm you to prevent you from asking
them or do anything there and then go in
and just act on normal nonchalant is
and never catching the guy knowing what
he's doing is just it just sets off the
alarms for me
ahead of this the jury heard a motion
from defense attorney kevin gough
the fact that mr brian aided and abetted
a citizen arrest if he did that
doesn't establish
malice in this case it doesn't establish
an intent to aid and a bet an intent for
a shooting
you know in your honor i would urge the
court to ponder the larger implications
of the legal ruling that the state is
requesting here there is no malice
murder case as mr bryant there is no
authority for this case
your honor the state wants to talk about
but four i want to talk about
intervening factors
let's bring back criminal defense
attorney julie reynoldman and co-host
terry austin terry goff saved his
opening until the end of the
prosecution's case do you think that was
effective
oh i think it was an excellent strategy
no doubt about it he waited until the
prosecution
ended their evidence and that gave him a
big advantage he's able to
do his opening and say this is what the
evidence showed not this is what i think
the evidence will show so his opening is
positioned right before the defense case
and that's another advantage it gives
the jury an opportunity to follow what
he said and to remember exactly what he
said so i think even though goff's
motions for instance the motion to not
allow black pastors in the courtroom
those are offensive i think this
strategy was a smart strategy and i
think it was effective and i
applaud him for it agreed especially
when you have the other two defense
attorneys already giving opening
statements they kind of carried some of
the load for him in the beginning and
now he gets to kind of clean up at the
end i think it did work well i agree
with you there terry uh julie the direct
of travis mcmichael what do you think so
far uh the defense brought out that was
helpful for their case and what do you
think the prosecution will question him
on cross he continues to talk about the
word de-escalate um and
everything he did was quite the opposite
of de-escalate um he you know he gave a
situation and where he thought he was
being carjacked show them the gun and
that's all he did and they backed off
this is a scenario where he doesn't see
the guy doing anything but running away
and he chases him down with a gun gets
out of his vehicle and then holds the
gun to him and then that's when the the
fight ensues and so if i'm the
prosecutor i'm going to dive on the fact
that this is the opposite of
de-escalation this is escalation at its
finest and there's nothing he did in any
way shape or form to de-escalate in fact
and and was the direct and only cause of
everything that transpired yeah it's
interesting the use of the words the use
of the training that he's employing but
then when you actually see the actions
play out to your to your point julie it
seems to be counter-intuitive or
counter-productive to what de-escalation
is it's gonna be interesting to see how
that cross-examination plays out
when we come back the tiger king is back
law and crime daily sits down with joe
exotic's attorney who says his client
deserves another trial the latest on the
so-called tiger king after the break
welcome back to law and crime daily on
the heels of the tiger king 2 premier
docu-series front man joe exotic fights
to overturn a murder-for-hire conviction
exotic whose legal name is joseph
maldonado passage rose to fame at the
height of the coven 19 pandemic when the
smash hit tiger king was released on
netflix the series documented joe
exotic's passion for tigers and his feud
with carol baskets an animal rights
activist who he claims kills her husband
don lewis lewis went missing in 1997 and
was declared illegally dead in 2002. in
2019 joe exotic was convicted on 17
counts of animal abuse relating to his
care of exotic animals at the gw zoo in
oklahoma he was also convicted on two
counts of attempted murder for hire
stemming from a plot to kill baskin
right now joe exotic is being held in
the fort worth medical center federal
prison as he is treated for prostate
cancer law and crime daily spoke with
his attorney who says their team is
working toward an overturned conviction
and a new trial based on government
misconduct and new evidence in the case
on the murder for hire people need to
realize this wasn't
federal agents looking back on a series
of facts and saying oh this person spoke
to this person and this person spoke to
this person
and
they plotted a murder
no the government was there long before
this happened and hired witnesses
uh confidential informants
to
essentially get words out of joe's mouth
and how that went down and the cross
conversations weren't part of the first
trial what the federal agent essentially
was saying to these people to to say
look this is what the jury needs to hear
for joe to be convicted
that's that's kind of what i learned to
be textbook entrapment anybody that's
followed this knows that
joe's still in prison
and carol's still not in prison
and there's there's still stuff going on
with doc angel and jeff lowe in the
legal spheres and so
we don't have a resolution yet just if
you look around that's the difference
between tiger king one and tiger king
two
julie do you see any grounds to overturn
the tiger king's conviction here
so we already saw that the appellate
division had found an issue with regards
to sentencing but they didn't find an
issue with regards to the conviction
and so they've raised several points
already and it hasn't worked if there's
new evidence that establishes something
more than just simply saying oh he was
entrapped because keep in mind we have
the actual audios we know the
conversations between these individuals
and so a jury could have determined what
in any what if anything rose to
entrapment the appel division could have
as well there was no finding of that so
could something happen could something
new come out of course i just don't see
it at this stage
all right let's kind of follow that
track as well terry could more eyes on
this case similar to the free britney
movement push this case towards being
re-examined and possibly overturned
i definitely think that the more eyes on
the case the better it will be for joe
exotic the point is people think they
have a lot of sympathy for him because
he's gotten this 22-year conviction he
just said some things it wasn't serious
no one ended up getting killed he was
entrapped and he didn't technically
abuse animals at least that's what
they're saying so i think community
response will help well let's see how
this plays out thank you for joining us
here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
you